hello metaphysical milkshake listeners
and viewers it is irene wilson and i am
reza aslan raza i was listening to an
episode of our podcast the other day and
i just you actually listen to our
podcasts yeah i do i do i listen back to
them and i just want to say that your
audio is always so
just so clean and crisp oh
that's nice of you to say thank you well
you know that i'll tell you the key so
what i want to do is i make sure that
the microphone is exactly six inches
from my mouth and then i you have to
always make sure to practice your breath
work okay okay okay whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa hey hey rezza don't mansplain
to me okay
i was just playing i was paying you a
compliment man i don't need some
step-by-step instructions how to guide
chauvinist pig hey hey hey whoa what
what what's going on here what are you
doing man yeah well you know what i set
a trap and you fell right into it big
sheeping massive toxic testosterone all
right okay listen i was just trying to
give you some advice about how you see
we as men have this peculiar tendency to
interrupt
to pontificate to explain to lecture to
sermonize just like mr
frat boy right here
frat boy please this is a bit of an
overreaction i think you need to bring
it down
men have hey what men have a hard time
doing is listening
listening really listening and learning
especially from the better sex
women okay well
as as usual this whole like bizarre and
convoluted
way that you've brought this up actually
brings up a very important point which
is that
often as you and i are very familiar
with this women are just you know
smarter than men preach sister yeah
let's uh look at the pandemic right look
at the countries that were run by women
new zealand germany
taiwan finland these were all
female-led states and all of them saw
fewer deaths than male-led states yeah
you go girl this i think raises a very
fascinating question a question that we
want to to discuss uh on the show today
which is what can men learn from women
yes queen
no no now i don't think you're allowed
to say that that's not i think i'm sure
that's okay that's offense i'm trying to
be supportive
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
so
what can men learn from women yeah why
is it so hard for men to learn from
women why well see here's the thing this
is kind of unfair because both you and i
are married to very successful women yes
my wife jessica jackley is like you know
world-renowned social entrepreneur i
basically
i basically like used my wife as the
model for how to function in the world
you totally rode her coattails by the
way i totally wrote her a co i mean like
obviously she's my model for how to be a
parent because i was raised by wolves so
i don't really understand literal wolves
like persian wolves like persian
persian wolves sometimes you know on
like full moons i get a little bit itchy
uh
like my parents did my parents we were
immigrants to the country like
basically my parents entire philosophy
about parenting was
are you alive at the end of the day well
then i did my i did my job but like you
know jessica's like this incredible mom
she's got so much empathy like she
listens which is
weird she like takes their problems
seriously like to me a six-year-old's
problem isn't a real problem
[Music]
so yes she's my model for how to be a
parent but i'll be perfectly honest with
you she's like my model for how to
function in the world like how to talk
to people my wife holiday reinhorn is my
model for how to be a human being in the
world i because i feel the same way i
was raised by not by wolves by aliens
and
i honestly have and i talked about this
in my book that i would watch kids
like in the lunchroom and how they
interacted and someone would be like hey
bro how's it going and pat the other
person on the shoulder and be like oh
that's how normal teenage boys interact
so then i would go up to someone and be
like hey bro how's it going
and i would
i would models and i would pat them on
the shoulder but honestly like
my wife holiday like she really helps
run our non-profit she helps raise our
son she she's a tai chi master
and she's deeply spiritual her prayer
and meditation practice her her kind of
therapy practice like she lives her life
so deeply and with such thoughtfulness
and kindness to everyone like
you know
i
i find myself asking my advice of her
you know 10 times a day so obviously in
our lives we have we have learned this
lesson in a very sort of deep and
emotional way about like how to how to
basically be more like a woman how to be
more like
you know the women that we have that we
have married
uh but i wonder like what about in a
global sense you know like what can what
can the world's men learn from my wife
i mean
women in general so good thing we have a
brilliant woman here to teach us to
guide us to show us the way into the
huddle we have the incredible brooke
baldwin to unpack this very perplexing
question she's an american journalist uh
she's an author she was the anchor of a
cnn newsroom with brooke baldwin for i
don't know like 30 years maybe something
like that her documentary to catch a
serial killer won a silver world medal
for best investigative report
and two thousand wait wait wait wait did
they did they catch the serial killer
they made a documentary
about it
it's promised in the documentary i bet
you if they had caught the serial killer
she would have gotten the gold award not
the silver yeah but then they should
have titled it to try to catch a serial
killer
and of course she's the author of a
brand new book called huddle how women
unlock their collective power
brook baldwin
what's up hi
you look so sunned and rested and
vacation hair don't care is this what
happens when you leave cable news this
is what happens you just uh
you just move to uh a small beachy
island in the caribbean forever and ever
amen
wow
leaving cnn really agrees with you i
gained 20 pounds when i left cnn so i
just was not working you left under very
different circumstances
you were [ __ ] canned the book is called
huddle nice segue uh we're really
excited to talk to you about this book i
greatly enjoyed it thank you rayne
there's uh a lot of really
interesting ideas packed into this uh
but i want to start with the title so
such an important word it drives the
entirety of the book and the
conversation in and around the book
um
what does huddling mean how did you
arrive at that word and uh what are all
the resonances of that word huddle it's
fantastic thank you i i was hoping it'd
be a sticky word you know and i brought
i came
it's a word i chose with intention you
think of huddle i think of a bunch of
guys on the football field right and we
know that men have been huddling you
know in terms of sports or socially for
years and years and years as have women
but we just haven't had a word for it
and i was like why don't we take this
super masculine seeming laced word flip
it on his head feminize it legitimize it
name it and own it as women like it's a
noun it's a verb um and how i'm roughly
defining huddle is you know a place
where women are energized by just the
the the mirror
that just the mirror the fact of their
coexistence right it can be it can be uh
where women come together to pray to
protest or to sweat it's like the moms
you know whose backs you're looking out
for or the co-workers who who you know
you want to succeed like their success
is your success and um i just think like
collectives of women get amazing [ __ ]
done and i wanted to write a book about
it see i like the fact that you were
like i need to figure out a kind of a
sticky word a sticky idea because i feel
like that's so much a part of
you know a lot of these books that have
come out very very successful books that
that are talking about you know new ways
of of thinking about feminism or or how
women should act in a certain way
there's like lean in boss lady and uh
this to me it's
it's almost like lean on instead of lean
in exactly that's how i that's how i
think about it uh trademark i'm gonna
write that down hold on i think i might
have written that in the book so uh oh i
had it first i had it first
i totally understand how important that
is but like what what is it that
separates
this concept from some of these other
ones that i was mentioning that i've
also tried to kind of
create new frameworks for women to think
about um themselves as individuals and
as collectives sure i think the biggest
difference is you're bringing intention
to huddling and the shared goal is
building an entirely new table for women
like we all love and of course admired
shirley chisholm and her quote about
like if you don't have a seat at the
chair
seat at the table bring a folding chair
and so this is the notion from all these
various huddles of women i talked to
everyone from reese witherspoon's you
know production company in santa monica
hello sunshine to stacey abrams and her
huddles of women who helped them you
know flip georgia
um
flip georgia blue to you know certain
members of congress to women athletes
like they they're all successful they're
they're not because they're these you
know lone success for successors or
outliers it's because they are huddlers
because they know how to unlock their
collective power ah so so really the the
key difference here is it's about
working together as a group
so that everyone can benefit from it
right like having each other's backs and
like supporting each other because so
many of these other books i've noticed
are all about like you go girl you can
do it by yourself and go out there and
show them who's boss and lean in and and
you're like well maybe we need a little
support system here we need a total
support system and i think some of that
stuff i think some of that like girl
boss and
pink pink wave and it feels pejorative
it feels you know and and i listen i
love cheryl sandberg's book lean in and
that was that had a role at that time
but i think that like the tide has
turned and i think even just from my own
experience like i felt like there was
this tidal wave between the trump you
know trump election and the women's
march and me too and time's up and all
the women running for election in 2018
you know at every single national state
and local levels it just felt like this
giant surge uh with women and they were
doing it in a collective way and i
thought that was interesting like i've
been a journalist for 20 years but i've
never noticed women
coming together to succeed to achieve
that one thing and it also is like you
know i mean i'm down for a good like why
night with the girls but that's just
sort of that could be haphazard and
you're just kind of hanging out or a
happy hour and this is different this
again it's like having the intention
what are we going to achieve
why are we coming together
what's the goal well we're we're
discussing today what can men
learn from women and we'll get more to
that as the discussion progresses but
yeah what i'm also hearing and uh
brother i think you brought this up in a
really great way is when you're talking
about huddling you're talking about this
collective energy and this collaboration
consultation you know all the all the co
words um
as opposed to some kind of girl boss
[ __ ] kind of thing which is like women
co-opting kind of a more masculine
stance in the workplace this is this
saying i don't want to mansplain it but
the book seems to be saying kind of like
hey one of our powers
is collectivism and totally consulting
and supporting and that's this is what
women
specifically have been doing
for you know past hundred thousand years
so um
is is this
i don't i don't want to give anything
away is this one of the things that men
can
take from women is um
a more collective action that is that is
proactively nurturing
yes i think for so long like women have
tried so hard to obviously we want to be
successful we want to rise up in the
workplace or you know kick ass on the
soccer field or what have you and a lot
of times like we try well we're like
well the men are paid more and are in
most of those higher positions and so
thus we know we need to like emulate how
men walk through the world but you know
like if i may
[ __ ] that you know like why can't we
just
show up as we are show up vulnerably ask
for help something that women don't
really often like to do because we don't
want to be a burden on one another we
inherently have the sisterhood i mean i
talked to this black historian kimberly
springer who was like brook black women
specifically and that's why i wanted to
start my huddle journey in houston with
those black women judges
black women have been huddling in this
country you know you go back to slavery
right so like four centuries where you
know their husbands or their partners
would be would be on the auction block
and be sold at the end of the day it'd
be the women who would have each other's
backs like they huddled out of necessity
but a lot of these black a lot of black
women specifically told me you know but
it it predates slavery in the way that
black women have genuinely enjoyed one
another's company and then of course you
look at like the womanist movement and
the million women march you go into the
80s and the 90s and it's just like never
stopped versus like white women and i
talked to kristen goss this duke
professor was like there was a bit of a
huddle drought in the 80s 90s and 2000s
with white women which ps is like
essentially my lifetime
and so i i knew i wasn't totally nuts
when i noticed having covered the 2016
presidential election and noticing a lot
of women showing up for one another um a
left right and center that some
something was happening in america that
i hadn't seen in a long time but i think
rain to ultimately answer your question
i think
we don't we just need to be together and
we need to show up as ourselves together
and not try to act like anything else
the black judicial candidates story that
you were talking about did you write
about the
i guess
19 19
black
judicial candidates in harris county
texas and they all decided
what if we all run together you know as
a as a group like instead of you know
picking on each other and i guess 17 of
17 out of the 19 won is that right they
all won in this in this very red
district and a mad imagine you know i
sat with six of them over brunch and in
houston one weekend for hours and they
were like and then each of them you know
has an extraordinary number of years as
a lawyer you know prosecuting cases and
they would say to me brook like think of
the number of times we would even go in
front of a black judge like they were
like we could count on one hand and the
idea of going in front of a black woman
judge
you know was the one woman held up her
pinky like that's that's that's how rare
it is and the fact that they all had won
their primaries and they all show up in
this smallish room and they don't they
don't know they're all running and they
start looking around and they start
counting faces
19 black women were in this room and
they all were like you know what i'm
putting the word in their mouth we're
going to huddle we're going to run a
campaign together and even the
democratic party
they said
we don't like that idea like we don't
like a whole group of black women you
know rolling around harris county
together uh you know campaigning and
they
didn't listen
and they won and they are still huddling
from the bench like you know i stay in
touch with a lot of them and they're
still like in the middle of a trial it's
like a child care or a custody situation
and then one of the judges will have a
question and she'll literally hit pause
on the trial
we'll go down to her cell phone she's
got they called themselves black girl
magic so she like texts the black girl
magic you know text chain
and is like a puts out an sos and is not
afraid to ask about you know the penal
code or what have you
and so you know they're hoping as black
women as black mothers can you imagine
you know trying to change the face of
the justice system in harris county
texas
the black women magic text chain reza we
will never be a part of that
we have to just let that go
this episode is brought to you by four
sigmatic a wellness company that is well
known for its delicious mushroom coffee
and you're thinking to yourself i'm
sorry did you say mushroom coffee reza
yeah i said mushroom coffee and
it is
incredible it's real organic fair trade
single origin arabica coffee with lion's
mane mushroom for productivity and chaga
mushroom for immune support it's like
the coffee that you normally drink but
more delicious and it works better and i
know because i've been starting my day
with four sigmatics ground mushroom
coffee this was so extra delicious and
smooth and believe me it does not taste
like mushrooms no i'm not gonna taste
any mushrooms it just kind of like
takes away that acidic aftertaste kind
of balances it out and all four sigmatic
products are organic vegan gluten-free
plus every single batch is third-party
lab tested to ensure its purity and
safety so you know you're getting the
highest quality coffee and mushrooms we
have worked out an exclusive offer with
four sigmatic on their best-selling
mushroom coffee but this is just for
metaphysical milkshake listeners get up
to 40 off plus free shipping on mushroom
coffee bundles now to claim this deal
you must go to 4sigmatic.com
milkshake this offer is only for
metaphysical milkshake listeners and is
not available on their regular website
you'll save up to 40 and get free
shipping so right now go to
foursigmatic.com which is f o u r s i g
m a t i c
dot com
slash milkshake and fuel your
productivity and creativity with some
delicious mushroom coffee
this podcast is sponsored by better help
is there something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist i just want to
say that therapy has been incredibly
helpful to me throughout my life the
past 20 years off and on that i have
been engaging in therapy spending
50 minutes a week looking at my own
personal
patterns of behavior that might be
setting me back
and at better help you can start
communicating in under 48 hours it's not
a crisis line it's not self-help it is
professional counseling done securely
online there's a broad range of
expertise available which may not be
locally available in many areas i've
known ray in a long time and he is much
more likable
since therapy
so betterhelp wants you to start living
a happier life today so visit their
website read their testimonials they're
posted daily on the site you can go to
betterhelp.com
milkshake that's betterhelp
and join the over one million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people
have been using better help that they're
now recruiting additional counselors in
all 50 states and there's a special
offer
just for our metaphysical milkshake
listeners you can get 10 off your entire
first month
at betterhelp.com
milkshake take care of yourself people
take care of yourself we love you
since we have one of the world's top
journalists and incredibly accomplished
and a powerful dynamic woman let's shift
a little bit and say how do we fix the
media since we're here might as well
just have a little bit do you have any
thoughts on that
i think we need to be covering like
telling stories like i think um it
should be
across the board as much as we can
understanding number one what's happened
with um americans as a result of
politics and this like crevasse between
the left and the right and how you know
that of course like biden kept talking
about the word unify but i have a lot of
friends let's say on the the left who
were like i don't want to unify with the
right and how do we how do we tell that
story right how do we how do we get we
need to send correspondents all
throughout america and i think cnn does
do this and we have i mean sarah seidner
is one of my favorite favorite favorites
and i mean she goes in she's a black
woman who goes in to try to understand
like what's happening within white
supremacy and and
we need to be telling those stories in
addition to you know as we have in the
wake of the derek chovin trial and
what's happening with the racial
reckoning in america to you know stories
that i think are undercovered um you
know within i loved how the wnba
dedicated their season last season to
briana taylor in the say her name
campaign and i wanted him to get more
attention and as the wnba season gets
ready for the next season like
why aren't we talking about them more
why aren't we talking about like huddles
don't often make the headlines um it's
not always like the sexy story it's not
the clickbait it's not the argument on
tv but i would i would balance it out a
little bit more no but i mean look i
think i think part of this issue and
this is this is the perfect segue to our
larger question which is um you know
what can men learn from from women
uh
i would say there's a lot in my view
that is wrong with cable news but i
think one of the biggest issues and this
is why i'm so curious about like how
would the news be different if women ran
it instead of men
one of the biggest issues to me is that
so much of cable news is predicated on
telling the story from the perspective
of the people in power like
i got fired
solely because
uh
there was this fear that somehow my
words would uh impede upon cnn's access
to donald trump
right like what if we can't what if we
can't interview him what if we can't get
access to power was that what was
explained to you yes in in sort of in
certain terms like he won't come on any
of our shows by the way was not coming
on anyone's show you were talking about
you know the black lives matter the
police right matters you know this idea
of
looking at it from the perspective of
the police or the government or the
people in charge instead of
the people being affected
um and i feel like you know if there's
anything that the data
that we have access to says about
women is that women are by far um more
empathetic they are more cooperative
they uh their leadership tends to be
more transformational instead of more
transactional
um
you know they're better multitaskers i
mean there's like all these you know
sort of surveys that show that women in
leadership positions bring
um
certain aspects to those positions
that are i think to me at least
necessarily going to be on the side of
the downtrodden and the oppressed and
less so on
the oppressor and the people in power
that's interesting that's interesting
this goes alongside with something that
you mentioned earlier when i was like
how do we fix the news media and you
were like more story about stories about
huddles but i like reza what you're
saying because we do see to me the news
just kind of reflects the system as it
is and perpetuates it by saying hey
here's the men in power and what they
think let's put them on this pedestal
and get you know and see the news from
their perspective
like i can't crawl into the head and
heart of a male news executive right all
i can know is what it feels like when
i'm sitting at that desk live every day
for two hours and the kinds of people i
want to talk to and this is just my
lived experience as a woman and i want
to talk to well-known people i want to
talk to ordinary extraordinary people
who
like to understand how why people are
doing the things that they're doing why
they tick and it doesn't have to be a
person in power at all
and i i would want to as i said before i
would want to you know as we as we have
like talk to people in minneapolis you
know in the thick of the racial
reckoning i think you also though have
to have access to the police you have to
you have to cover it in a holistic way
um but i wonder
at this interest that's actually really
interesting your perspective that you
feel like men in charge then only want
to have the men in power and you know
listen i
i agree that i think we should cover
i think we have to cover the people in
power but we also have to cover
the the regular folks in extraordinary
circumstances and i wish we did that
more um and that is the that is what i
loved
doing and there has been a focus these
last few years to those people in power
but understandably those people in power
pull the strings and
create you know sign laws and the rest
of it and so it's like you have to have
you have to have both but it should be
balanced and so i think having women in
charge
and men
would help balance it out instead of it
being like this
shifting gears a little bit
um
my friend justin baldoni wrote this book
called man enough um
and
it's essentially about toxic masculinity
but i was talking to him about the book
and he was saying
he can't really use the phrase toxic
masculinity because so many men hear
that and just immediately shut down have
a knee-jerk negative reaction get
defensive immediately so if we're
talking about what men can learn from
women and the concept of huddling is so
beautiful and powerful at the same time
um how do we
how do we get this across
to
kind of white male mid-america which in
my mind and
deepest apologies listener um i'm going
totally against the joe roger
roganification of america but
they're part of the problem not the
solution you know from anything from gun
control to black lives matter to the
environment to even wearing masks in
public being an imp impedition imp
impediment on their freedom um so many
white
men
30s through 60s let's say
seem to be holding things back and could
so greatly benefit from
huddling and
kind of maybe
taking on some of the more positive
characteristics
of the feminine
and i i don't want to sound like a
granola crunchy hippy dippy 1972 like go
home commie like wimpy male kind of but
at the same time like
we i feel
like we could be stronger
the more feminine we are is or should we
even be worrying about that and their
reaction to this conversation you know a
lot of a lot of people who deal in
racial justice issues said listen we
tried for decades to not to walk in
eggshells and not step on your toes of
of white men and we're talking about
these issues and
guess what nothing changed nothing got
better so
now we don't give a [ __ ] about that
we're going to step on toes and we're
going to break eggs eggshells in having
these discussions
i mean just as
we were talking earlier about like why
should women have to act like men to be
successful why should men have to
feminize for for whatever reason i'm
just a big believer in showing up as
whoever the [ __ ] you are like if if you
are
rougher be rough if you are softer be
soft but i don't think it's like you
don't you shouldn't be a fraud you
shouldn't you shouldn't act like how you
think you should for for whatever reason
to to to be the woo-woo granola or to be
the tough chick in the office or to
to have sex like a man or whatever
whatever it may be to me when i think of
men and and helping like support the
huddle i think of men in the workplace
who have positions of power who are
hiring other women who are adding you
know child care practices for not only
women but like promoting paternity leave
and like telling men
take the in time off like go help your
your partner raise the kid um you know i
was talking to abby wambach for uh ig
live recently like she's the badass
soccer star and she was telling me this
story of you know she's a i'm sure she's
paid well and she should be as keynotes
as a keynote speaker and she was like up
for some giant keynote speaker gig and
she was up against this other guy and
the ceo of this company male she didn't
tell me the name of the company but she
said ultimately she got the keynote job
and the ceo of the company who picked
abby called her up afterwards and was
like hey i'm gonna tell you that the guy
you were up against who we almost chose
was asking for three times the amount of
money you are asking for and like you
need to know that and you need to be
asking for more money for yourself and
like that's the kind of stuff i'm
talking about like having men share
salary information or like sweeteners
and contracts hey like i got this thing
this exists like women are like amazing
i got a contract and i'm only getting
paid this but like i'm so grateful like
that needs to change and we need guys to
say this is what i'm making or this is
what this guy was making you know like
embolden us to ask for more that's how
you can help the huddle we look you're
preaching to the choir i mean both reign
and i we talked about this earlier uh
absolutely rely on our wives
yeah and i was gonna fire reza and
replace him with a woman and pay her
twice as much but twice as much that
would mean
two buckets of chicken a week wow
[Laughter]
folks your online checking account
shouldn't cost you money that's why
chime an award-winning app and debit
card has listened to me here no
overdraft fees no foreign transaction
fees no monthly service fees and no
transfer fees folks do we realize how
many fees we're paying with credit cards
and with debit cards it is constant you
withdraw money you get fees
you
charge you get fees there's percentage
run up every month and i know you're
probably sitting there thinking to
yourself yeah but like you know i need
to use atms wherever i can find them
well guess what
chime has over 60 000
fee free in-network atms at locations
like walgreens or 7-eleven or cvs lots
of places that's more than the top three
national banks combined you can also
send money to anyone even if they aren't
on chime no fees for you or cash out
fees for them so it's time to say
goodbye to hidden fees join the millions
of americans already loving chime
sign up only takes two minutes and it
doesn't affect your credit score you
ready to change things it's only going
to take you two minutes get started
today go to
dot com
slash milkshake that's c-h-i-m-e dot com
slash milkshake okay this is the part
where we do the really fast talking at
the end yeah you try it go for it here
we go banking services provided by and
debit card issued by the bank court bank
or stride bank n a members fdic out of
network atm withdrawal fees apply except
that money pass atm and a 711 location
and at any all point or visa plus
alliance atm other fees such as third
party and cash deposit fees may apply
boom well done thanks chime for
sponsoring our podcast
i still think we're missing something
here i mean
to say that men can best support women
by sharing contract information and make
sure they're hiring them
you know i i i still i want to go back
to this joe roganification of america
like the concept brook of huddling to
men
is weakness
men who
are weak women who huddle are strong
that's the whole thesis of your book i'm
sorry for some mansplaining but we have
a [ __ ] ton to learn from women that's it
give a [ __ ] ton rez and i were talking
about what we have to learn and what we
have learned from our wives you know
this whole idea of like how men lead
individualistic you know emotionless
showing emotion or vulnerability is
weakness the alpha male the whole idea
of like of interrupting and and yeah and
mansplaining and knowing best and if you
show doubt or consult with people that's
weakness so i i think that there's
foundationally
we could all
go back to 1972 and munching some
granola and men need to kind of like
we need to wimpify a little bit but can
i push back on you just a little bit in
saying that you don't think that for
years men have looked out for their
buddies and they've had a position to
open and they'll grab this guy over this
person um like how men have huddled and
have you know there has been this
favoritism among like circles of men and
oh let's go out and like you know crush
some numbers and do whatever on a golf
course like we come back we exclude the
women and therefore like the men are
still running the show and caring about
themselves like i i would i would argue
that there has been a little bit of that
you're absolutely right no question but
when i read your book
um
i see the definition of huddle a little
bit differently you know
and it's all throughout your book it's
not just hey let's help each other out
and help no totally totally it's it's
also about let's support each other
let's put our arms around each other
let's share with each other let's let's
you know consult and say hey i'm
struggling with this what are you
struggling with this let's work together
toward this end so you know did they
have men huddled up to the exclusion of
women for centuries and and you know had
this huddle and excluded women no
question yes yes yes yes but what we're
talking about the theme here is what can
men learn from women and you know i
think men can learn those other aspects
of huddling um
not just with each other but with with
all of humanity no it's 29 year old
stacey abrams when she was the deputy
city attorney in atlanta the first
access of power she had she acted as a
sponsor she was surrounded by a bunch of
really intelligent but low-level
secretaries who had this extraordinary
legislative knowledge of georgia she
needed them should they deserve more
money she had her first taste of power
she goes to the city of atlanta and
she's like hey let's help them get a bit
more education thus like raising their
salary caps it's a win-win situation
it's ava duvernay black successful woman
filmmaker in you know hollywood who is
amplifying other younger women women of
color in order to direct queen sugar
thus creating this pipeline of more
women in a very white male dominated
space you know to be able to then go on
to direct network television it's you
know women shannon watts and
congresswoman mcbath creating the
largest grassroots huddle in america
being moms to man action six million
strong and yes it's men included in that
number as well but it's how they were
they were able to come together and now
change laws and create you know as they
would say gun sense legislation it's how
women hockey players and soccer players
and you know basketball players have
come together to fight for
uh you know equal rights it's it's it's
how they've all managed to you're right
durane i'm just coming back to yes it is
that is that is huddling yeah that is
how you achieve amazing [ __ ] and that is
the special sauce with women in the
collective maybe i'm oversimplifying it
but it sounds like that the fundamental
difference at least in my experience of
men huddling is that yes it's true like
we're always like you know on
trying to help each other out but
but there's always a kind of this would
be better for me to feel to it like yeah
dude i'll totally get you the job
because it'll be fun to hang out yeah
dude i'll totally write the
recommendation because it it it somehow
it always comes back to me self-serving
yes but the huddling that you're talking
about stacey abrams ava duvernay it
doesn't really have anything to do with
them it's for the greater good yeah it's
just for the the betterment of the group
so maybe that's really what it is you
know i mean i i know there's a lot of
different ways that we can talk about
how how men can learn from women and how
you know uh men need to learn to lead
more like women it's it's that this
conception that
it doesn't have to be transactional
mm-hmm the huddling doesn't have to be
transactions yeah exactly that i get um
and that there's this sort of notion of
you know what's good for you is good for
everyone that that feel that's really i
think missing i have to say in my
experience and i've had a lot of benefit
from other guys you know that's so
interesting so on that note then you
nailed it by the way both of you get it
i think that was so well said well done
gentlemen
no you connected the dots really well
there reza i'll give you some props i'm
not gonna fire you the um may i have
more chicken please uh you can have
another pot of chicken
but i love that idea cause all those all
those that list of amazing huddles brook
that you just talked about like they all
had a cause they had a goal they strove
for something to make the world a better
place it wasn't about like
yes it was certainly about pay equity
but it wasn't about like how can i get
more out of this situation let's let's
bring it to a close here which is
you mentioned a couple of things very
specific things that men can do to help
support women um tell us like how how do
how to woke guys
like me and rain
how do we how
i'm like barely woke by the way i've got
a little baby so i'm like i'm like half
woke
how can we
be
better allies
um
to to women i mean there i guess that's
that was it yeah was that is there a
more complicated way for me to ask that
question
i was like how does could i say that but
that's it how can i be a better ally no
thank you for asking the question and
thank you for being
you know two woke dudes talking to
talking to a lady about huddling on on
this podcast um i mean i think in
addition to all the things i mentioned
before it's really simple it's just like
it's it's
men should support women huddling should
support women coming together should not
see it as something threatening um or
taking away from them uh and it's also
not something pejorative it's it's it's
it matters and for me and my own you
know
later in life learning to huddle and
activating a huddle and nurturing a
huddle and hopefully inspiring other
women to huddle it's it's made me just a
better human you know in learning to
huddle with other women it's made me a
better you know partner to my husband
it's made me a better journalist it's
just made me a more
awake vulnerable communicative
caring human and i think as long as men
can just
see that and
want that for other women that's a win
full stop
[Applause]
[Music]
well brook baldwin uh what an amazing
discussion and uh got so much out of it
i am so ready to huddle reza will you
huddle with me i'll i'll huddle with you
anytime excellent so what we do with all
our guests uh and i'm excited to hear
what you have to say is a lightning
round ready lightning round
brook baldwin when do you feel most
connected with the universe right when i
wake up in the morning
early if you were stranded on a deserted
island and i don't mean like the resort
island that you're currently stranded on
uh name three items that you would bring
with you i would bring my journal
i would bring my bob marley box set
and
that's just assuming i could play it
yeah right and i'm still talking about
like i'm like i'm in the 90s
all my cassettes
and
a bottle of dumb
so not your husband interesting okay
good to know okay yeah what emotion do
you wish you could better control oh
patience
if you could trade places with any man
in the world who would it be and why you
know
i would love to know what it feels to
walk in the shoes of my good friend and
the commander in the navy bobby rashad
jones we are both from atlanta he is
black i am white he grew up in a very
different existence as me and we have
had many very tough conversations in the
last few years about
how he walks through the world versus me
and i would want to know
i would want to just start to i can
barely understand that as a privileged
white woman and i would i would want to
know what it feels like to be him yeah
great answer
what's one eye-opening experience every
person should have
covering the water skiing squirrel like
really great sex like really
really
really great sex i'll tell you all about
it later rain
what is something uh hardly anyone knows
about you describe your soul in 10 words
or less kind
adventurous
authentic
um
funny
whole-hearted
curious
if you had five minutes with tucker
carlson uh in a dark shed and no one was
the wiser how would you spend those five
minutes also in this scenario you have a
baseball bat i would start with his
childhood
i would want to understand
where he comes from
how he was raised why are you laughing
because it's like the perfect answer to
what men can learn from women
yep
with that one question she's leaning
back and trying to understand trying to
understand like that's what happened to
you what happened to you yeah that's
what i would want to understand just
like how did what how did it all start
name something that a lot of people like
but you just can't stand eggplant
if you could have lunch with any author
past or present who would it be brene
brown and if hollywood was making a
biopic about your life who would play
you
kate winslet that's a good one yeah okay
we'll we'll see what we can do about
that yeah finally what is your life's
big question what is my purpose for the
greater good
brook baldwin i've been a fan of yours
for a very long time the book is called
huddle
get your hands on it people men women
everyone can learn from this look at all
that rain learn from it i learned so
much you guys are so great so great do i
get the bucket of chicken now or is this
just
that that's how i survive is that bucket
of chicken don't take that away from me
so reza i meant it i want to huddle with
you you ready to huddle with me that's
not a sexual thing right you mean just
that like you see i manned it didn't i i
d i did a major thing i took an
emotional moment and then i immediately
you did
it so how how can we huddle more how can
we help each other more let's huddle up
right now you're working on a new book
you've got a couple of shows going
you're producing uh what about al
whatever that sitcom is called
how can i
huddle up and help you all right i'm
gonna be um honest and a little bit
vulnerable okay here but um
get me on [ __ ] star trek somehow like
any way i don't care how like i'll die
in the first few seconds of the show
yeah i whatever it takes would you play
that would you play a dead body i would
play a dead body i will play an alien i
will
i will play i'll i'll just do the voice
of a of a robot i'll be like the voice
of an alien species let me hear your
alien voice right now let me let me just
hear what that would sound like i am an
alien oh no no no no i can help you
listen you have 17 kids you want me to
do some babysitting fine that's the only
thing i wanted but that's fine okay how
can i how can i help you then right how
can i huddle with you with no no benefit
to me whatsoever put me on star trek
well i'm writing a new book
you're a way better writer than i am
will you
write it for me
will you ghost write my book
oh [ __ ] how much chicken is is it is
there in it for 10 000 chicken we're in
oh look at that we're going to help each
other lifetime supply of chicken that
way i made it transactional because i'm
a man but i learned something from brook
baldwin which is doesn't have to be for
my benefit
for the benefit of all humanity i will
help you with your book for the benefit
of all humanity and i will babysit your
children for the benefit of your
marriage all right how about you dear
listener yeah how can you huddle up are
there people that you can think of in
your life that you want to huddle with
that is team up arms around each other
with a greater goal a greater sense of
purpose has this conversation um opened
your mind shifted your perspective at
all we'd love to hear from you
okay so you know we've said this before
we will say it again all you got to do
is go to apple podcasts rate and review
metaphysical milkshake ask your life's
big question and if it's good enough if
it's something we're interested in
we're going to invite you to come on the
show ask us that question in person we
will answer it solve your problems
make your life that much easier and and
more productive so we have uh someone
here who had a very very interesting
question this is rayne and i we love
this question if you want to get on the
show figure out some way to ask some
version of this question and we will
very likely bring you on this is derek
russell from california hi derek hey
how's it going guys derek what's
happening what's on your mind yeah so i
wanted to ask you guys about ai you know
um it's the cutting edge technology
these days and my main question was
you know with ai
um there's kind of like this debate are
we in the robot revolution has a robot
revolution already happened
will it happen but also
tying into that i want to ask about ai
and kind of like let's just say the
morality of it all you know um you know
like thinking like we're on the cutting
edge with like self-driving cars
self-driving trains like and if we get
to this point where we can fully
automate that
morally
should we not have any humans involved
you know a plane flying a ton of
passengers no no humans
you know i'm i got a lot on my mind guys
you know there's so many ways to
approach the ai question i mean there's
so many ways in to this issue you know
two of them pop into my mind one is that
as a.i increases we're going to see a
big change in kind of the employment
landscape so
um if there's if it's self-driving
trucks
how many
tens of millions of truck drivers are
out of work you know if it's
if it's a i picking vegetables how many
farm workers are out of are out of work
so
you know this this can go on and on and
are we equipped as a society to deal
with this kind of new wave of
unemployment i mean we've already seen
it's been a slow shift from the assembly
line being mostly people to being mostly
machine but that took decades but the
upcoming changes could be very very
swift so there is a morality question
around that like what do we owe as a
society to our workforce and
do we have another way to you know to
fit these
workers
to plug them in to some other kind of
profession or educate them or or
relocate them the other morality uh
question around this is you know if we
create an ai that has its own
consciousness
um i'm i'm really fascinated by the by
the problem of consciousness what they
call the hard problem of consciousness
because for the kind of secular atheist
materialist
uh way of looking at things the fact
that we have consciousness doesn't make
any sense the fact that we
um
have emotions and feelings and that we
witness our lives as kind of an ever
unfolding movie in front of our eyes
that there's a a beginning middle and an
end that we have a self-identity that we
have personality traits that
you know we have you know memories and
we can write an opera and all of this
kind of stuff does not actually lead to
the survival of the species why do we
have that and why do we have it and
octopuses don't as far as we know but
if we're going to create ai
that has consciousness ever increasing
consciousness there could be a point in
the not too distant future 50 years 100
years where we're creating an ai that
has a similar
kind of interactive
consciousness
driven mode of being in the world of
having a memory when it's created and
having thoughts and feelings and
perceptions and personality and putting
things together and um
you know just just as
as we are and then do we have the right
to create that and do we have the right
to then end the life of something that
is having that kind of experience now i
know that this is the subject of many a
science fiction film
um
including spielberg's ai nonetheless i
find it incredibly fascinating so i
don't have any answers but um it is a
crazy new world out there that's so
fascinating because you're right like
the people who reject the whole mind
body dualism who believe that whatever
consciousness is
it's fundamentally
you know the workings of the brain so
it's like it's a
an issue of matter
if that's true and i'm not sure it is
true but if that's true then why
couldn't we recreate it in a machine
right
do the right coding you put the right
things together and
there you go the machine has
consciousness and i love your your view
is like well then what do we do with the
machine but the other more moral
question is what about us then like then
are we we're nothing we're just machines
that's all we are except but just not as
good because we're flesh and blood
instead of
metal
but the one thing and i'm glad you
brought up every movie every ai movie
uh
the one thing that always gets me is
that i think those movies have prepped
us to think of a.i
as like a robot like an ai is this being
this bipedal being with a head and a
mouth and it looks just like us
well the ai revolution is already here
and the movies that always predict that
ai will inevitably destroy humanity
that's already happening it's called
facebook i mean right facebook is
is run by an artificial intelligence so
i'm not a scientist here but the
difference between a robot and an
artificial intelligence is that a robot
does the thing that you program and an
artificial intelligence learns on its
own and essentially does its own program
based on the desire that you give it so
a robot you say pick up that box and put
it on the shelf and ai you say clean the
room and then the ai learns how to clean
the room the best way and for those of
you who are already familiar with this i
apologize uh for for telling you
something you know already but
facebook facebook has an ai the purpose
of which is to keep people on facebook
that's the whole purpose
they told the ai
keep people
on facebook
and the ai on its own
discovered that the way you keep people
on facebook is how rain you make them
outraged yeah piss them off if you piss
them off they will stay on facebook and
the news works in the same way because
you know as reza is always reminding me
you know the news
is entertainment
so we have genocides
uh you know race riots
uh anti-vaxx you know uh information
like
a pandemic out of control
because of the of an ai so this like
futuristic world where we eventually
develop an artificial intelligence that
ends up killing us we've been living in
that world for a decade already it's
called facebook but i do like that
that way of thinking reza that we need
to stop thinking of ai as as an entity
as a bipedal like hello i am a robot and
get out of that completely and see it
more as an algorithm you know it's it's
much closer to skynet than it is to
like a cute little robot from a
spielberg movie but derek what are you
what are your thoughts how what what are
you thinking is this is this guard loose
any any of your thoughts on that on the
ai revolution it makes me think that
maybe robots and ai don't need a face
we think of it kind of like behind the
scenes and like maybe that's for
um maybe that's intentional you know
they don't a lot of times
you know um there's one aspect of ai
where people trying to make it seem more
human like you go on a call center and
you go through and it's trying to answer
those questions for you it's trying to
be human-like
but also there's this sort of aspect
where yeah a lot of times these machines
and systems that we use are controlled
by ai you know think about it like i was
talking about
i came in kind of concerned about let's
say if robots were placed pilots but
when you book a flight it's not like one
person just did the math right there
it's a whole system that's built out
so we're already kind of relying on
these systems that are
not human so
derek thanks so much for writing in to
metaphysical milkshake folks listening
as we've repeated before
just go to apple podcasts leave us a
nice review
and
talk about your metaphysical question
and we may bring you on the show we
would love to bring
fans and listeners and random human
beings and random ai
intelligences that may be listening out
there we'd love to have you on
metaphysical milkshake
yeah find us on socials at reza aslan
and at rayne wilson you can find us on
instagram metaphysical milkshake or on
twitter at
metamilkpodcast let us know your life's
big question
we just might explore them on a future
episode and remember to follow rate and
review metaphysical milkshake on apple
podcasts and wherever else you listen to
podcasts
and of course you can also subscribe to
metaphysical milkshakes youtube channel
watch our full episodes every week thank
you brooke baldwin for diving deep
thanks for watching see you next time
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samazadeh yazd harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubell cast media is
the production and distribution partner
it is edited by tyler newbold and audio
mixed by justin kyle original music by
jeff tang
okay serious question um would i have
gotten fired if cnn were run by women
it's a very serious question
no comments for those tuning in reza had
a hit show on cnn one of their biggest
hit shows following anthony bourdain a
believer in which he investigated
different religions and he said he
tweeted donald trump as a piece of [ __ ]
fact check true he got [ __ ] canned
immediately do you stand by your tweet
hell yes i stand by my tweet
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you